Tom Tom tu dois la rencontrer
salut Evelyn Jack bon nom donc
tu prends un écart ici oui j'espère en quelque sorte que
cela deviendra plus une vie d'écart vraiment tu
devrais aller voir cette fille Hé d'
accord,
docteur d'amour je  je vais dans un club tu
veux venir tu ne veux pas de nouilles ou
quelque chose à propos de tes poignées tout à fait le
charmeur n'est-il pas qu'est-ce que tu aimes comment
il pense que j'ai appelé je prends des photos ne la
laisse pas s'enfuir ce qu'il aimait tout
d'accord qu'est-ce que vous aimez les filles que vous avez fait
pour guérir votre petite amie ce n'était pas vraiment
comme ça elle m'a largué hé ne vous
approchez pas de ça c'est trop de stress
elle est dans mon orteil n'est-elle pas
tout à notre enfant tu ne voudrais même pas  essaie
tu aimes jouer à ce petit jeu n'est-ce
pas comment on joue à nouveau
ces choses inverses pas pour moi tu
ne peux pas juste changer tes plans je peux
changer mes plans Tom je suis un adulte donc on
fait quelque chose
[Musique]
je viens  ne comprends pas
qu'est-ce que ça ne va pas bien nous
te trouvons environ sept minutes oh tu ferais
mieux de commencer
[Musique]
là  il y a quelque chose à propos de toi jack n'est pas
là